what are the five biggest mistakes
screenwriters make well I don't know if
I'm gonna do five off the top of my head
but I will say under estimating the
importance of structure a good structure
is you know I feel like that's one two
three and four right is is gonna paint
the way it's going to it is the story
structure is story right I was not you
know will that the William Goldman is
the one who said that it is determining
character development so all of those I
really do think one through four are the
importance of structure and then if I
had to say a fifth thing I want to say
it's sort of a contradictory thing that
you need to be both tougher on yourself
and you need to be easier on yourself
that I see writers do things like
they'll say to a friend you know maybe a
friends more accomplished writer than
they are and they'll say you know I
finished my draft would you read it it's
not very good
why are you bothering your friend the
Moriscos writer to read your draft
that's not very good
uh-huh right you need to you need to put
a little more effort into it you need to
be a little harder on yourself and you
should think your draft is very good
before you are opening it up for
feedback right you're kind of wasting
the expertise of those around you if
you're sharing drafts when you don't
think they're very good at the same time
you kind of need to be easier on
yourself so be harder on yourself in the
sense that did don't bug your friend
until your script is in a good place but
but also be kind to yourself that you
know there's a lot of what makes people
successful is luck is dumb luck you know
and they're people who are more
challenging than you that are successful
other people who less challenge is the
new that are successful so give yourself
a break that no no script is going to be
perfect even a great writer
can and I've seen writers kind of killed
themselves doing Draft after Draft after
draft
and obsessing and getting contradictory
notes and then they don't know what
they're doing and they and driving
themselves crazy because they're being a
little too hard on themselves at some
point you got to let it be you you got a
you know once you feel good about it
you've done some good drafts on it you
feel good you've gotten some good
feedback from your writing group or
people you trust not everyone's gonna
like it
got to put it out in the world and relax
you know and somebody you know you're
gonna get some notes back that aren't
what you agree with don't obsess about
it and try to because you can't please
everyone with your book the nutshell
technique which chapter is most debated
by people whether it's a friendly debate
or whether it's outright people are
these very severe beliefs about I'll say
the most confusion is the concept of the
want right so the very first thing I
talk about is that in the first scene
the character has something that they
will want that they get in the point of
no return this is the trickiest piece
for some reason and I have two chapters
on it's actually the only element I
devote two chapters to for this reason I
try to and this is just from years of
experience that I've learned this I try
to help people by calling it and
explaining and it's still and and yet
still there's confusion about this this
one that I'm talking about here I call
it the set up want it is not necessarily
the characters greatest want it is not
necessarily the characters biggest
motivation and and yet people still do
that that they still think it's well my
character wants one thing and according
to Jill's nutshell technique they have
to get it in the point of no return
but that doesn't work with my point of
no return my point that I've tried to
make clear is that your character just
like your character has multiple flaws
they have multiple things that they want
there's not a one-to-one
relationship between watts a point of no
return your character wants multiple
things all I'm saying is that there's
one watt that they get in the point of
no return it may not be their biggest
want it may not be their defining one it
may not be the thing that they say that
they want it's just something they want
so I call it sometimes I call it a
throwaway want sometimes your character
just wants a sandwich all we're doing is
we're setting up this little piece I
call though this be careful what you
wish for what happens in the point of no
return so be careful and don't think
that that makes a movie not applied to
the nut shell technique because you
it didn't seem like the character got
what they wanted I talked about in
Groundhog Day
his most obvious it's been because it's
a great example of this point his most
obvious what he talks about in the first
scene he thinks that there's a network
that's scouting him for a big Network
job right that's his most obvious one he
wants a big Network job he doesn't get
that wand right I'm not saying he
doesn't want it he says he wants it I
believe him it's just not the set up
wand so you need to look and find
something else that the character wants
that they get so I'm not negating the
fact that Phil Connor wants a network
job I'm not negating the fact that Phil
Connor wants women to worship Him he
wants lots of things he's not gonna get
just like we all want lots of things we
don't get the thing that he wants that
he gets it's a little throwaway line he
says basically that he doesn't want to
spend more than 24 hours in pub cet'aeni
it's a little throwaway line Matt in
fact it wasn't in the three versions of
the screenplay that I looked at at
researching this for this book
interesting yeah it was very late in the
process that they also discovered we're
missing something we're missing
something that makes Phil even Phil this
jerk isn't a victim of the universe
suddenly making him stuck on one day he
kind of in the original drafts was kind
of a victim
this thing happened to have many stuck
the writers at a very latent process
because it's not in the three scripts
I've seen but some place between those
three drafts and the movie it was shot
they added a scene where he says to the
substitute weatherman that wants us
wants to spend more time covering for
him when he's in when he's in pucks
Otani Hill says please like I want to
spend an extra second in pucks a time
it's a throwaway line I don't want to
spend more than 24 hours in Punxsutawney
we're just setting up be careful what
you wish for because he got his why he
only has to spend 24 hours in
Punxsutawney right except for there's a
big catch he's gonna have to spend the
same 24 hours over and over again
so the want is a set up one I put it I
call it a step walk with quotes around
it it's not necessarily the characters
big want can we use an example from
Chinatown okay Jack Nicholson's
character like an initial want he meets
Faye Dunaway yeah what's his first like
one want that he gets that's not really
his real want well I don't know but I'll
tell you what the real one is but so it
so the set up one we're gonna find in
the literally their first scene so it's
before he meets Faye Dunaway it would be
in that very first scene when he's got
curly sitting across from him Curly's
that client he's showing the pictures of
curly as with the cheating cheating
who's been cheating on him right and
curlies like sobbing all over the place
right so what he wants is what he
doesn't have here he wants a classic
case cuz this you know cheating wives
thing is not really classy so what he
wants is a classic case who wants
something classier than what he's
getting
he gets that in the the main case that's
going to be Chinatown the catch is it's
got corruption all over it right he's a
lot bigger than he thought it was it's
not even the wife Yeah right
interesting okay yeah just so that's
that's kind of his his initial want yeah
he wants a class your case he thinks he
gets it he gets this femme fatale that
comes in
that turns out it's a whole mess of
trouble but he doesn't realized that
yeah yeah right so the one revving its a
throw it's a throwaway thing that if
they say interesting you know in Juno's
got another nice example I talked about
in the book that the wat is it's it's a
really clever one actually um where it's
the scene where she's drinking the
SunnyD cuz she's taking the pregnancy
test and she's trying to pee oh right
she's drinking the SunnyD she's and she
sees an old discarded chair somebody
left on out on the curb and that reminds
her of like it puts her flash back of
her having sex with Polly the moment
that got her pregnant
and the thing that she wants she's just
looking at a chair she wants to save
something that's being discarded the
chair that she pulls and she puts on
Polly's lawn is sort of this active
right and then what's that how does she
save something that's being discarded at
the point of no return what's the point
of no return and Juno do you remember hi
dawn it's been a few years is it
something with her babysitting job no
she is planning she goes she's pregnant
she's goes for an abortion yeah that's
right she can't go through the abortion
that's right so she's gonna save
something that was about to be discarded
a fetus so what we're doing is you're
getting your walk but you're getting it
with ironing right in the beginning she
just wanted to save a chance right okay
right so she's and it fritz
I call it a throwaway want and yet it
also fits with her character really
nicely she's someone who kind of saves
discarded things she gave has a
hamburger phone you know and people like
Polly who sort of discarded so it's very
fitting in a character so she wants to
save this discarded living room set but
then she goes to save a fetus that she
was thought she could discard and
discovers that's a lot harder than she
thought it was going to be
you